whether they're comedy Legends or action
icons these actors said no thanks to a
major follow-up film with no apparent
regrets like many on this list Bill
Murray isn't exactly known for his
friendliness towards follow-ups but his
resume isn't totally exempt from them
either case in point Garfield A Tale of
Two Kitties so do you have any regrets
Garfield maybe but despite his dual
outings as the lasagna loving fat cat
Murray failed to return as Bosley and
Charlie's Angels Full Throttle after a
reported Feud with co-star Lucy Liu and
director McGee but naturally or maybe
supernaturally it's his history with
Ghostbusters that's drawn the most
public interest and controversy over the
years Murray who starred in Ghostbusters
and Ghostbusters 2 famously refused to
have anything to do with the ill-fated
and unproduced Ghostbusters 3 because he
wasn't impressed with the idea much to
Dan aykroyd's Chagrin in an interview
with variety Murray commented I read one
that Danny Aykroyd wrote that was crazy
bizarre and too crazy to comprehend
Murray did however agree to make a cameo
in Paul feig's all-female reboot as a
sign of solidarity for the new
generation of ladies battling
ectoplasmic goo he even voiced Peter
Venkman in Ghostbusters the video game
which was effectively a third film
Murray finally returned albeit briefly
to bust some ghosts in the 2021 sequel
reboot Ghostbusters afterlife which
brought back the original Heroes to pass
their proton packs over to the next
generation of paranormal investigators
known best for his action roles in The
Matrix and John Wick franchises Keanu
Reeves has become something of a staple
in the genre in 1994 speed was a
breakthrough success for Reeves helping
to make him recognizable for more than
just his goofy Antics in Bill and Ted's
Excellent Adventure and Point Break
speak
certified him as a bona fide action star
years before the Matrix but Reeves
wanted nothing to do with a speed sequel
in an appearance on Jimmy Kimmel he
explained what turned him off to a
reunion with co-star Sandra Bullock and
director Jan de Bonte saying I got the
script and I read it and was like Ugh it
was about a cruise ship and I was
thinking a bus a cruise ship speed bus
but then the cruise ship is even slower
I just can't do it Speed 2 cruise
control went ahead with Jason Patrick in
the lead but was hated by critics and
audiences alike though Reeves opted out
of returning for cruise control would he
consider returning for Speed 3 while
nothing is officially in the works after
encores in The Matrix resurrections Bill
and Ted face the music and John Wick
chapter four maybe anything is possible
yeah not really
though The Dark Knight is the most
successful of Christopher Nolan's famed
Batman Trilogy the first installment
Batman Begins is not to be slept on the
film focuses on Christian Bale's Bruce
Wayne as he slowly turns into Batman
starring opposite bail is Katie Holmes
who plays Bruce's childhood friend and
love interest Rachel Dobbs among the
only characters to learn that Bruce is
Batman Rachel is pretty pivotal to the
film though she'd be recast in the
sequel the real reason why Katie Holmes
declined to return for The Dark Knight
is something only she truly knows but
there's plenty of speculation to go
around the public line on why she gave a
hard pass to the movie and the
substantial paycheck involved was that
it conflicted with her shooting schedule
on Mad Money an all-female buddy crime
comedy unfortunately almost nobody saw
that picture which flopped big time at
the box office
other sources such as Yahoo movies have
suggested that Holmes's marriage to Tom
Cruise might have impacted her decision
but no matter the cause Holmes made it
clear that the decision was hers and
told MTV that she had no regrets about
leaving Gotham City
back to the future may well be the best
sci-fi movie of all time a time
traveling coming-of-age adventure the
film solidified Michael J fox and
Christopher Lloyd in the pop culture
Zeitgeist to this day it's one of the
most beloved films in cinema history and
while the reception to its sequels is
admittedly mixed the original remains a
favorite among audiences everywhere
among the spectacular cast is Crispin
Glover who played Marty's father George
McFly in a heartwarming hero story but
even though his character was slated to
return in Back to the Future Part 2.
Glover ducked out of the sequel and its
eventual continuation Back to the Future
Part 3. according to Glover he stepped
back due to salary and creative
disagreements with producers who instead
of recasting the role used his likeness
by molding his old man mask from the
first movie into something usable for
the second the whole thing is a bit
strange and unsettling Glover who was
understandably annoyed sued the studio
for using his likeness without his
permission and one because of my my
lawsuit There are rules in the Screen
Actors Guild that make it so producers
can never do something like that again
I'm proud of the lawsuit somehow both
Back to the Future sequels may do
without ever showing Marty's father
again although they alluded to George
McFly in their own unique ways it helped
that the third one mostly took place in
the old west the first two X-Men movies
helped revolutionize the superhero genre
when comic book movies were nearly at a
standstill in fact Brian singer's second
attempt at reimagining the X-Men for
modern day audiences X2 X-Men United is
still considered among the franchise's
best the film introduced us to Alan
Cummings Kurt Wagner a mutant later
codenamed Nightcrawler by his allies
but decided against returning
for X-Men the Last Stand despite the
Fanfare surrounding his portrayal of the
teleporting mutant the actor hated the
intense makeup process involved and even
claimed that the set was abusive X-Men
the official game which took place
between X2 and the Last Stand explains
that Nightcrawler has left the team
deeming their lives too violent for a
peaceful man
interestingly coming admitted to being a
bit nostalgic about the role around the
time X-Men first Class rolled around
because this film started a new timeline
for the X-Men Universe Nightcrawler was
recast with Cody Smith McPhee playing a
much younger variation for X-Men
apocalypse and its 2019 follow-up dark
Phoenix
one good way to ensure your leading lady
won't bother to come back for a second
film is to kill her off in the first
scene of the script such was the case
with Gina Davis who declined an
opportunity to appear in what would have
basically been a cameo role in 1989's
The Fly 2. she's gone
after being such a big part of the Jeff
Goldblum LED original which is actually
a remake Davis's absence is definitely
felt in the sequel though to be fair
Goldblum is missed also he at least
appears via archival footage but even
that wasn't enough to save the film
leftover footage of Davis's character
Veronica quaif from the fly along with
substitute work by actress saffron
Henderson made up for her absence during
the brief portions her character
appeared the sequel which followed the
story of Veronica's son with Seth
brundlefly brendel didn't do well not
only were Goldblum and Davis absent but
director David Cronenberg producer
Stuart kornfeld and co-writer Charles
Edward Pogue also bowed out
interestingly Goldblum whose character
didn't make it out of the original alive
has recently shown interest in returning
for another fly movie but it's doubtful
that Gina Davis would join him
bridesmaids was a sassy No Holds Barred
unapologetically Brazen comedy that left
audiences begging for more directed by
Paul feig the 2011 film was a success on
every level beloved by critics and
audiences alike in fact it quickly
became producer Judd Apatow's highest
grossing film at least at the time but
despite the film's undeniable success
star and co-writer Kristen Wiig has no
desire to return for a second round
either in front of or behind the camera
in an interview with Harper's Bazaar wig
explained we knew during the first one
this was it we would have made a lot of
money if there was a second one but
that's not my goal in my creative life
echoing wig's sentiments and honoring
her vision director Paul feig said it
was pretty much up to wig alone as to
whether a sequel would happen
since we still haven't seen Bridesmaids
2 announced it seems like wig is
sticking to her guns on this one
when asked by e-news whether she'd
consider making another bridesmaids film
without wig's involvement her co-star
Melissa McCarthy responded God I
wouldn't want to I would never want to I
think it's a terrible idea after a
decade of speculation and rumors
surrounding a potential sequel that just
about settles that
as come what may as his characters are
you might not expect Will Ferrell to be
a choosy guy but there's one role feral
has no interest in revisiting there will
be no sequel to the 2003 hit elf you sit
on a throne of Lies the holiday comedy
was certainly on the nice list when it
came to box office receipts but when the
studio raised the idea of pharaoh
reprising his most recognizable
character he wasn't interested Farrell
told USA Today I just think it would
look slightly pathetic if I tried to
squeeze back in the elf tights buddy the
middle-aged elf lose the tights I mean
as soon as possible as soon as possible
as soon as possible as a result a
follow-up to the holiday box office
smash still hasn't happened and likely
never will but maybe that's a good thing
other hit Christmas comedies such as the
Santa Claus have done well with second
installments but for every Santa Clause
2 there's also a Christmas vacation too
and Buddy the elf doesn't need any of
that
Forrest Gump was one of many career
defining performances for Tom Hanks it
earned him his second consecutive
Academy Award for best actor along with
endless jokes about his box of
chocolates Mantra and his undying love
for his peas and carrots pal Jenny my
mom always said life was like a box of
chocolates
you never know what you're going to get
although forest's story comes to a
natural conclusion by the film's end
there is actually Source material for a
sequel Winston groom's follow-up novel
Gump and Company which was released a
year after the film premiered and
follows forest's life through the 1980s
despite multiple attempts at a sequel
there are plenty of reasons that Forrest
Gump 2 was never made including the
September 11th terrorist attacks but the
biggest reason was Tom Hanks himself
Hanks held out on reprising the role
despite reported attempts by the studio
to get Gump pardon the pun up and
running again back in 2022 Hanks told
variety I will say that with a long time
in between we did take a stab at talking
about another Forest Gump that lasted
all of 40 minutes I've always said if
there's a reason to do it let's do it
but you guys can't force me sounds like
Hanks is perfectly content leaving
Forest back in the 90s or rather the 80s
Robert Duvall is one of Cinema's most
prolific actors with roles in films like
Apocalypse Now the judge open range and
plenty of others going all the way back
to To Kill a Mockingbird and Beyond
Duvall has quite the filmography under
his belt and an Academy Award to show
for it of course one of his most famous
performances comes from a movie that is
still considered by many as the greatest
film of all time The Godfather
playing the role of Tom Hagen in The
Godfather and its immediate sequel
Duvall was a dynamic presence on screen
and Hagen like most characters in the
picture was not one to be trifled with
but by the time the Godfather Part 3
rolled around Duvall was no longer
interested in returning to a life of
crime especially if the pay wasn't up to
Snuff in a 2004 interview with 60
minutes too Duvall said if they paid Al
Pacino twice what they paid me that's
fine but not three or four times which
is what they did in response to Duvall's
absence The Godfather Part 3 notes that
Hagen died sometime before the film's
events while new characters assumed the
legal responsibilities of the Corleone
family's criminal Empire
though it would have been nice to see
Hagin return not even Duval could save
part 3 from becoming the most hated of
Francis Ford Coppola's iconic gangster
trilogy
first appearing as a scared young woman
in the 1984 sci-fi horror feature the
Terminator Linda Hamilton took on the
role of Sarah mother of the human
resistance Conor with ease by the time
we saw her again in the even more
impressive 1991 sequel Terminator 2
Judgment Day she transformed herself
into a warrior who was nearly as
formidable as the titular cyborg himself
broke my arm there are 215 bones in the
human body that's one now don't move
though T2 is the gold standard of
Terminator movies a three cool titled
Terminator 3 rise of the Machines was
released just over a decade later unlike
the first two the third wasn't directed
by James Cameron and didn't star
Hamilton opposite Arnold Schwarzenegger
Hamilton told MTV I read it and I knew
my character Arc was so complete in the
first two Sarah died halfway through and
there was no time to mourn her it was
kind of disposable so I said no thank
you
while she refused T3 Hamilton reprized
her role vocally for Terminator
Salvation though she avoided the
franchise for another decade afterwards
Sarah Connor was recast in both
Terminator the Sarah Connor Chronicles
and Terminator Genesis before Cameron
convinced Hamilton to return one last
time for 2019's Terminator dark fate
sadly the film flopped leaving Hamilton
disillusioned after its release she told
The Hollywood Reporter I would be quite
happy to never return I would really
love to be done more than likely she'll
get her wish
who doesn't love Marlon Brando
this cinematic Legend starred in A
Streetcar Named Desire on the waterfront
Apocalypse Now and even received top
billing in Superman the movie even
though he played the man of Steel's
father and not the hero himself but we
all know that Brando is best known for
his iconic performance as Vito Corleone
patriarch of the infamous crime family
in The Godfather
friendship
you don't even think to call me
Godfather though Don Corleone was the
breakout character for the first film
Brando wouldn't return for either
Godfather sequel Robert De Niro played a
younger veto in flashback sequences for
The Godfather part 2. though Brando was
initially scheduled to appear at the end
somewhat famously Brando failed to show
up for the film's final scene a
flashback to the era before the first
film and director Francis Ford Coppola
quickly reworked the scene to proceed
without him evidently it was an offer he
could easily refuse
similarly in 1980 Brando scenes were
removed from Superman 2 due to a lawsuit
between the actor and the film's
producers who cited creative differences
as the reason behind the omission though
these scenes were lost for years the
original director Richard Donner re-cut
the film in 2006 according to his
original Vision re-adding Brando's final
scenes as Superman's father jorel
Brando's Darrell returned once more
posthumously in Brian singer's Superman
Returns through repurposed archival
footage from 1978's Superman
the original James Bond Sean Connery is
notable for his dashing good looks
swashbuckling demeanor and unmistakable
Scottish accent but even he has been
known to pass on a sequel in his time
Connery finished his initial run as bond
with his fifth appearance in 1967's You
Only Live Twice Connery returned to the
role four years later after his first
replacement George Lazenby left the
series following one film to Star his
bond in 1971's diamonds are forever his
final 007 film for Eon Productions
Connery was replaced by Roger Moore who
played bond in the next seven films
Connery returned for Never Say Never
Again which was made outside the
official Canon and would actually prove
to be his last tying him and more for
the most appearances as 007 ironically
Connery confessed to the guardian that
I've always hated that damn James Bond
that explains his periodic retirements
but this isn't the only franchise
Connery exited in 2006 Connery retired
from acting and thus opted out of
returning as Henry Jones senior in
Indiana Jones in the Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull he told The Hollywood
Reporter I spoke with Spielberg but it
didn't work out it was not that generous
apart worth getting back into the
harness and go for her instead Jones
senior was said to have died off screen
and was honored with a passing Cameo via
a photograph
while sometimes recasting is necessary
and lives up to expectations sometimes
the exact opposite is true though she
played the role of Evelyn Evie O'Connor
in the mummy and The Mummy Returns
Rachel Vice decided against reprising
the role for a third time Vice wasn't
the only one who didn't make it back for
the mummy Tomb of the Dragon Emperor
director Steven Summers handed over the
Reigns to Rob Cullen though he remained
on board as a producer rather than a
casual scheduling conflict or retirement
Vice simply didn't like the script which
had been penned by Smallville creators
Alfred Goff and Miles Miller according
to Cohen he got an angry phone call from
vice's agent explaining that the then 37
year old actress wasn't interested in
her character having a 21 year old son
in the movie aside from not liking her
character's Direction Vice had also just
had a baby and wasn't available for a
five-month trip to China
given vice's frustrations with the
script and her inability to travel the
filmmakers rewrote the Eevee character
entirely and recast making her nearly
unrecognizable
honestly I can say she's a completely
different person Maria Bello didn't do a
bad job she just wasn't the Evie
O'Connor we all knew and loved whether
it was the lack of Rachel Vice a poor
script or just poor timing Tomb of the
Dragon Emperor crashed and burned and
the mummy franchise has yet to fully
recover
movement